what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
start up pacemaker over here on hbo max
i know we're getting to see you guys a
little bit late i don't really know what
the upload title is going to be like for
this at the moment there's some stuff in
our personal lives we're kind of having
to manage a little bit more but we'll
try to get these to you as soon as
possible but in the meantime you guys
can go ahead hit that like button that
would mean the world the suicide squad
absolutely love that movie so i'm very
much excited for this show subscribe
click that notification bell get
notified when our reactions the next one
is up and uh as always full length watch
alongs where you sync up with the time
code for peacemaker will be over at our
patreon page become a super object today
by checking out all the content we have
to offer over there thanks to all who
have joined so far and thank you to the
boys over prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights
all right guys
let's make america great again
[Music]
you're shot and a building falls on you
and all you have to replace is a
clavicle
you're the luckiest man alive
explained
what superhero are you peacemaker get
out of here [ __ ] you're a fan
there's
dude i'm [ __ ] famous you're not that
famous aquaman he's famous [ __ ] woman
[Laughter]
especially not nowadays
he starts [ __ ] fish let's take care
of steps
guy on twitter works for the aquarium
said for 50 bucks he brings him in the
back so he can have his way with a
sturgeon
oh
peacemaker yes you're that racist
superhero
no
if somebody's committing a crime yes am
i supposed to control what their
ethnicity is no but you need to watch
white people as closely as you watch
people of color so you see more of them
committing crimes fine that's that's a
good point
[Laughter]
what i need to know is on the deal is
there anybody out there looking for me
not that i heard of man no cops outside
nothing i ain't seen no cops i can just
go why not
[Laughter]
ah
yes this is uh this is gonna be a good
one yeah i'm very excited right now
[Music]
this is timing
oh my god
wow
oh hell yes
go do it
yes
i love that this is the intro
yes
yes robert patrick
i have this is one of the best openings
ever
oh he even made it
in i gotta go okay love you love you too
are they gay you might be right theories
go back and revisit that
it's
50 cents but maybe it's a million bucks
what's in the bag
[Music]
oh
hey it's v are you
dude dude i realize in that last message
i called you p and me v as if you were a
penis and i was a vagina
[Laughter]
stay where you are smith
oh
domestic situation known as project
butterfly as i recall you guys aren't
particularly creative with case file
names
arctic starfish was a giant walking
starfish
what am i fighting them off right now
i am
fighting with the football fighter
that's not what
i get
that jet pack better show up before the
end of the season we need you to do
contract work kill people bad people
whom we call
butterfly what if i say no you'll have
to return the bell reef was to keep me
from splitting still have that bomb in
your head to track you with and if that
fails
we'll blow you the hell up that's right
that they removed for him yeah tough
luck
i just got swung by my dad to get eagly
who's eager
you should do your research
it's my sidekick the name of his eagle
eagley
what else would it be
evil super villain not a super villain
that's a misconception i'm a superhero
batman is a superhero yeah oh betflick
if you're gonna make up a person why
make up a person with such a long name
i'm so sorry i don't spend all my
[ __ ] time thinking of realistic
selling last names you're wrinkly old
[ __ ] hey dad
[ __ ] you
somebody shot me a building fell on me
you let somebody shoot you
i invited them don't shoot me dead
pathetic
i really already like their chemistry a
lot i've been paying for service for
years because you forgot oh
it's my fault now you [ __ ] up and went
that's not what i'm saying then what are
you saying it's my service i got no
money jesus christ you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you've been taking igli out
yeah
where is he
legally yes
you can come up with a better name
oh that's so
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
dad look how excited he is
there's a great effect
it's just
awesome right
[Music]
oh
i want one i want an eagle hug
they really do seem like they could be a
father and son i know it's crazy
even just to look at them
and this other member of the team rat
catcher she controls rats you know how
he got the phobia of course i don't
[ __ ] know how he got it he was
tortured his own father tortured him by
locking him in a crate for 24 hours with
nothing but starving rats
do not give him ideas
[Music]
please god don't tell me he was the one
who shot you
oh
that's right eagley you know a lot of
what happened in cartoon maltese is
confidential
how did my [ __ ] sperm i went to a
nancy boy like you look i just came by
to get eagly and see if you had another
element for me goddamn vm's going you
could write a freaking good script can't
you
it's madness
building to weave in and out of town so
yeah
whoa
whoa daddy's got some secrets
this has sonic blast capabilities
you need to breathe underwater then this
is the one for you it's like dexter's
lab in here
my living room was full of pigeons are
you kidding me no there was like 10 of
them and they [ __ ] all over my couch
this guy
hey sweet cheeks oh can you take my
order real quick uh it makes green salad
and we'll do the garlic zoodles
zoodles good choice thank you
choice
any validation at all
zoodles are zucchini noodles
sweets
we cheeks is your butt no it's not it is
it's like calling somebody i don't know
sugar tits it's totally inappropriate
chits are way too big to be sugar tits
trigger sets are like smaller perfect
tits like
kelly i think you may have sugar too
keep talking
hey
hey bud
oh [ __ ] man i thought you said it was
friendly oh i thought you meant friendly
to me
[Laughter]
you said you heard stories about mr
murray i know he's a mercenary i know he
killed a lot of people not always for
the right side i know i don't trust his
ass well good night smith
not ever small
although i do appreciate the confidence
with which you said something so wrong
i'm the big dick yep information i had
no need for
no i'm i'm serious
it's too big actually
causes people pain okay kids at junior
high they call me chimp arm
that wasn't inappropriate was it easy
i love that eagle
is that a real eagle that has to be
right i i think it's the cg effect i
think it's a really good one all the
budget went into the eagle yes
the eagle and some wide-angle lenses
you know you don't have to call me
peacemaker you can call me chris i'll
call you peacemaker you call me harcourt
how's that i'm just trying to say it
doesn't always have to be about work
hold on okay the [ __ ] did you say to my
friends
what was that next
ugly [ __ ] god
any of the rest of you want to
finish him
oh that's cool shot yeah
yep a little bit of his dreams right
here
chimp arms coming back
that's so [ __ ] hot
i clocked you driving by and then making
a u-turn follow me in here oh you say it
makes it sound all stalkery no the way
that you did it made it stop
well done i'm not asking for emotional
connection here i'm just asking for fun
genital genital contact no touching
above here no [ __ ] it's got to be here i
gotta touch your boobs sorry
just trying to
i don't know relieve some of the
stresses oh my god they're actually
gonna do it you know what
[ __ ] yourself
chris
oh
they're not gonna do it ever she said oh
oh he's not gonna be able to do because
she used his name finally when telling
him to [ __ ] off
oh no ma'am as well
freedom of freedom
yeah
i'm not like these people
i have an early morning
night baby girl
nightmare
mom
i was wondering yeah
i don't trust her no way
choir boys went to see these guys when i
was a kid
god go to all the shows when they came
through evergreen
no don't drop too
big man many
this guy's way of saying chris there's
something more for you out there
you and eagley
other than all this rants and [ __ ]
life's throwing you so far
[Music]
[Music]
oh he's really getting cut yeah
huh she's gotta be like a creature or
something yeah it's like cheetah yeah
yeah i was gonna say
especially 1984 cheetah
what the [ __ ]
what is she
[Music]
very nice frame up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
oh
no
pecker eyes out eagerly
activate zombie move
whoa
nice
i love that damn eagle man
igly
they are insanely
an iconic duo
well done might as well let's see this
post credits
this one will give you scabies
let me escape why they're what skins
challenge yourself
every man should have scabies once in
his life
okay
[Laughter]
sure sure that's coming back at some
point one way to look at it man
[ __ ]
great premiere episode james gun love
continues to shine through in this work
man it's so it's just so apparent and i
love it so much of just like i love the
voice of james gunn uh immensely and
you know especially flashing back to a
lot more of his like earlier work and
you know it's like it doesn't go imagine
this show will get even darker like i
imagine it'll get dark
uh you get shades of that you know
because one thing i think he's so good
at doing like when he's when he's on it
when it comes to like nailing down
weaving in and out of tones is when i
think he just excels so much of his
ability to go through like the comedy
banter get really like out there with
the humor and then
through the characters not just like
here's an obvious joke and now an
obvious shift and dramatic beat it does
it through the characters responses like
i think the way like that robert patrick
scene
when they're at the table they're
laughing about reflecting on the blood
sport
moment like this whole time he's just he
just seeks validation so much from his
dad and he just wants to have like some
hint of approval or some form of
connection and he finally gets him to
open up and they're bonding over
something that's just so morbid and
messed up it's so funny because of
outlandish it is
and
that it turns it around into you know
like i hope it wasn't the guy who shot
you and of course you know like right
away they've painted such a good picture
of this this relationship and who this
man is
that obviously it wouldn't be a laughing
matter if it is the one who shot him it
would be something that would just cause
you more of a strain between them and
more of a negative outlook on his son so
i think what this show's doing so far
pretty solid stuff man it's it's pretty
great the action's good no john
what you say what you say what you say i
hated every minute of this i know i
agree 100 uh with what you just said and
it's been fun to watch james gunn's
voice
grow and mature over time because you
know this definitely has a lot of the
irreverence and a lot of the just wild
humor and you know
grit that james gunn things tend to have
but i feel like yeah this is a little
beyond even where like like i really
like super but that movie gets a bit
like out there in terms of just how
pulpy it wants to be and i love the
balance that he struck here because yeah
like it's really efficient in how it's
moving forward it's establishing what
the situation is for peacemaker post you
know suicide squad the suicide squad and
john cena is just he's just so great and
it's been really fun to watch him grow
as a performer and it's funny to me
because
on patreon this past week i watched an
episode of psych that guest starred john
cena and robert patrick as two military
characters and like his character was
very peacemaker-like and robert patrick
not as out there as this but he was his
superior a superior officer who he had
to deal with and so to watch them now
many many years later in this together
like john cena he's good in that and his
acting chops have you know steadily
improved i think but he's so great at
anchoring this with all those layers
with the humor with his boisterous o
fish uh you know nature but also those
tones like the second out of bio is like
there's something else about him i was
like yeah like that sadness and she's
sure enough says it and yeah it really
shines through and it's really
endearing and i think the hook that i
imagine is expanding here is that
examination of like yeah this guy was
raised by like the worst guy possible
and while he is well-meaning he has a
lot of those tendencies and
characteristics and i think it's going
to be really fun to watch the character
confronted across the show through that
lens
and beyond that i just thought the rest
of the ensemble was really sharp and
really well utilized in the scripting in
everyone's acting that fight scene with
harcourt was badass
you know yeah i was really enthralled by
this
that's pretty it's i think like the
introduction of the lyoda character
abedio had a bio
um at a bio it's
like that's that's what i think what
that james gunn does so well is
endearing you to a character so early on
like from their opening scene
and
like the opening scene of getting you
invested in the relationship that she
has that there's something at stake here
that if she does die yes but
reusing a character's kind of like human
cork like something that feels like a
relatable human quirk in order to
connect you even faster in a way that
doesn't feel like all right we've got
like the heart the dramatic hook
now let's have her give an awkwardly
rambling speech
that is like not at the right moment to
do the speech and it's not called upon
for whatsoever but when she does it it's
so funny and i think her acting there is
so good like she did a such a natural it
sounded like there's a real you know
that when you hear people's voice shake
when they truly are nervous yeah you
know like a lot of times actors i can
you could hear that it's like
i'm a good of course she didn't force it
and like she had such a natural tremble
to it
wow
it was impressive how something as
little as that really quick because
yeah i think what he did here you know
having a little bit of this
redneck vibe to it a small town vibe
this is more
of the kind of james gunn movie i think
nowadays with james gunn would you
usually i imagine the show will go
bigger this to me is the kind of thing
where it's like i love when you give him
the money to make the big budget
blockbuster films absolutely i think he
excels at that the suicide squad i
thought was absolutely incredible
um but here you're getting like both of
the james like this is like no this is
really the the mesh of what he
got
known for it you know following four and
now being able to use some of the bigger
set pieces as well but still keeping it
like i guess the word is grounded
it's like they have there's there's
qualities to it where it's more amusing
when something looks a little bit uh
out of date with technology like when
they go into robert patrick's closet or
uh
later i mean about the
of the way the designs are like this
feels very like out of the 80s or 70s
even earlier maybe like a different time
period yeah it feels outdated like but
it works yeah like a retro imagining of
what a futuristic secret layer lab would
look like yeah yeah that's a good way to
put it yeah and yeah it definitely feels
like it like you have those elements of
blockbuster james gunn with those trauma
like the fight with the girl in her
underwear is like definitely like a
troma james gunn moment exactly you know
and i i'm one i'm curious about how
people are responding to uh adrian chase
my my it's funny because i think um
i think when news about um dead
dead spot deadshot was not going to be
in in uh james gunn's the suicide squad
a lot of people were speculating that
idris could play vigilante obviously
come out as bloodsport and now they have
vigilante in this show and um you know
my most familiarity with vigilante from
very limited things i've read the most
familiar i have is like you know i
watched all of arrow so i have a very
much more like dramatic hefty
interpretation
of swab
adrian jason for me i'm like this is a
complete 180 in all aspects of who
adrian chase is in my mind
so i'm curious to see how people respond
to this character um you know as i i
honestly can't sit here and tell you
that yeah i've read comics where that is
a version of asian chase i truthfully
don't know i don't know if there's just
its own spin on it but some a character
like that even i i imagine it could be
kind of annoying uh but something was
funny about it like he actually was
funny got that abortion exchange yeah
yeah uh there was um this is a this is
something i think could shape into
something really special going on the
best opening credit scenes i've ever
seen too hundred percent
yeah and eagerly the inclusion of that
is like
john cena's acting is so like i remember
one of the first things when talking
about the suicide squad was like john
cena blew me away in that like i've
really believed him
and
here it's just his acting really has
evolved he's brought so much depth to
this character
uh i i'm so on board it's like i didn't
really watch the trailers for this show
and then to be coming back here into
this world it's like within a few
minutes that hospital scene where he's
like talking and setting up like uh he's
talking to the janitor
like oh wow i think i think i'm really
gonna like this show because it does a
good job at immediately not making you
wish you were watching the suicide squad
or make you think it's trying to be the
suicide squad on tv even though this is
most people's associate like that is the
association with john cena peacemaker is
that movie but this is totally different
and i think it's it throws you into like
his small town world who has to go on
big town big big
world missions yeah yeah i think it's a
really endearing spot to have him in
that place of like am i still under
arrest can i just get out of here you
know yeah and then yeah the the position
he winds himself in for however
heightened this is is i think uh one
that some folks out there probably could
relate to where it's like you'll either
go away for a long time or
you can help us yeah you know you can be
leveraged into this position and it does
make you sympathize for him as much as a
buffoon as he can be
you know
all right guys well thanks for being
here what do you think about peacemaker
keep a lookout for our reaction to the
next episode you can subscribe click
that bell hit that like button
maria hammond she sent us a package
we're gonna unbox it right now yeah
right here okay i see the back end of
two sweaters right now that's the first
thing i see right here you said these
are from england
oh oh my
maria
okay the cans not that fancy trying not
to look something fell okay first thing
here we got ourselves a nakatomi
corporation beanie
dude is that from that is from lethal
weapon four yes definitely yeah
definitely brutally works there it's
great to say john oh it says now i have
a machine gun ho ho ho from the beloved
uh you know crime comedy rush hour yeah
here you go set at christmas time
directed by brett ratner
yeah dude oh my god and then another
nakatomi corporation would you look at
that it's from 21 jump street hey
not a great match for this recurring
joke but you know it works still you did
it johnny you can have a christmas card
that's snow man thank you maria dude you
are a die-hard fan of the real regions
if anyone's not expendable it's you
oh thank you so much that's that's very
sweet of you you'll definitely see us
rocking these in videos halloween time
yes just to piss off the audiences thank
you that's really sweet thank you thanks
maria
[Music]